hi I'm Mary and I'm from Conroe Texas
just north of Houston the only thing
that I remember my dad saying about
money charges that way you don't have to
pay for
fast forward a number of years and I've
got a young son and I became one of
those women you can't trust with a
credit card and I thought that I was
doing okay with my money as long as I
was making these small purchases but I
realized later I was making a lot of
those little purchases and then
somewhere along the way somebody told me
about Dave Ramsey and I remembered
hearing you tell somebody wants that
they had a an income problem and that
was me I was 35 percent of my take-home
pay was going towards debt payment so I
was going along trying to get maybe step
one done and I knew it was going to be
months before I could even get to $300
saved up
so I gave up and I went straight to baby
step two and maybe that's part of being
single not having somebody else bounce
this off of I just didn't think that I
could do it but I actually had no hope
that I could ever do this what you do
have to have reinforcements you have to
have some kind of people around you
telling you not crazy in a world it's
crazy the turning point for me though
finally came when I became eligible for
retirement I finally decided this is it
this is where I draw the line in the
sand
well after 20 years working with the
state I went to work for blinds calm in
my case my change of job meant that
instead of driving 10 miles down the
road to work I was driving 50 miles down
the road I didn't have a clue what was
going on in fact I found myself
sometimes I would cry all the way to
work and does it have to be all nice and
happy and everything at work and pay
attention to I was doing and I would cry
all the way home that was really tough
that was really seriously tough but I
made it through I've been sharing at
work that I was going through this
journey and one of the ladies had been
through FPU so she loaned me her CDs to
listen to and once I was listening to
those I knew that I had to do SBU but I
waited for fu to go on sale on the site
the home study course and I got that
they flesh everything out in such an
amazing way that I just kept thinking I
wish I had done this a long time ago and
it really reframed the way you look at
things in my world it turned me
completely upside down because I'm
single one of the things is that I'm a
very very free spirit I think for
spending so I had to kind of depend on
my budget
every dollar really made that much
easier for me because it it has more to
it than I ever would have thought to put
on a spreadsheet every dollar could have
helped to be my partner but I have just
really really enjoyed knowing about
money for the first time in my life
knowing what a real budget is and
knowing that I have a future
you can wish to be out of debt but
wishing isn't going to make it so you
can even dream about it but the thing is
that when that dream turns into a
specific goal in a specific time and you
have a plan to work that and even when
you're single having that plan will help
you know where to go and how to get
there if you have waited this long to
start my word to you is it is never too
late you're not alone there are other
people doing this all over the country I
have done it I'm living proof you can do
it to me the biggest thing was getting
hope finding that hope that I could
really do this I'm here to tell you the
hope is there do what it takes
start start now today
three two one I'm dead Brad
my granddaughter and I came back from my
dream vacation at Walt Disney World
been a dream of mine since he was a
young child to take him there it was
such an emotional thing for me I just I
cried I cried at the end when they had
that fireworks it wasn't about the
extravaganza it was about standing there
with my son and my granddaughter and we
had done this to have that experience it
really has made me learn that dreams
when they're turned in to goals really
do come true
[Music]
you